community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
hospice volunteers provide peace comfort
and care to those in need and the
sponsors of this next segment southwest
medical is highlighting one of their
heroes rhiannon spirkle take a look
i've been a long time volunteer with
hospice
started eight years ago
seven years of those was in california
and i moved to vegas
two years in june and i've been doing it
since january through my own experiences
with three of my family members
in the uk
with hospice there
my experiences with
the staff that came in to volunteer who
gave us respite for all three especially
at night time that allowed us to go to
bed i was just overwhelmed by the
generosity and when the third
situation happened i came back home to
the us and decided i've got to give back
and reward
the people that helped us i think my
main role is uh companionship to
everybody that i've seen and respite for
the caregivers so they're able to
get things done while i sit with their
loved ones one activity i love to do
with a patient is puzzles it's one of my
favorite activities in the summer with
my kids
so when someone said they love to do
puzzles we were right on it and
the hour and 40 minutes just went so
fast it was just so much fun for the two
of us to sit down and do together just
last week with my patient she told me
don't waste your life go out and do
whatever you can while you have your
health they really teach me
it doesn't matter you know just live as
you want to and each day be grateful
i unwind generally on the golf course
here at southern highlands at the
fitness gym
five times a week i just
hash it out
stressing listening to music and
socializing with my girlfriends here on
the golf course if i could give one
reason for someone to step forward and
volunteer it would be to tell them that
you are given but you receive so
much more from the family
it's you become part of one of the
family it's it's gaining a grandparent
that you may not have and that's what i
feel
[Music]
there are so many aspects that bring me
joy
they're just
they're so happy to see me every time i
go in they grab my hand
oh i'm so happy to see you he's so nice
of you and even if i'm not visiting that
particular patient there will be
somebody else oh it's so nice of you to
do this and and that's what just makes
me happy that i know i'm making a little
bit of happiness to that person
in their day
my days are an upbeat after i've been
visiting just because i feel so happy
and
that i could help somebody make them
happy so my whole body is in a happy
mode
thank you to southwest medical hospice
care for sponsoring this segment for
more information or to become a
volunteer yourself call 702-671-1111
or visit the website on your screen
las vegas now we'll be right back